[Музика]
хлопці,
привіт усім і ласкаво просимо на
урок англійської, мене звати
Світлана рабетянка,
і сьогодні ми починаємо нову тему,
яку подивіться
на наших уроках, ми будемо говорити
з вами
про науку та технології, які
ви розширите  ваш словниковий запас,
практикуючи нові слова,
фрази та вирази, ви
вивчатимете пасивний залог, дізнаєтесь, як писати статтю
та опануйте нову мову та навички,
так що hi-fi і давайте приступимо до справи,
тому сьогодні ми говоримо про винахідників
та винахідників,
коли прихований ключ  винаходи перемагають
і підтема, як чудова ідея
може змінити наш спосіб життя,
щоб винахідники
могли згадати будь-які імена відомих
винахідників,
подумайте трохи, що вони за
Едісон Ейнштейн, хтось інший
хороший, ви дізнаєтесь більше, але якщо говорити
про
винахідників, давайте подумаємо, що це за
люди
, якими особистими рисами
чи характеристиками вони повинні володіти,
якщо вони обізнані, винахідливі,
працьовиті, без сумніву,
що ще давайте прочитаємо  Цитата,
і ми дізнаємося,
що винахідник дивиться на світ і
не
задоволений речами такими, якими вони є, він хоче
покращити
все, що він бачить, він хоче принести користь
світу,
його переслідує ідея, що дух
винаходу володіє ним,
шукаючи матеріалізації
тож винахідники
хочуть покращити світ,
зробити його кращим, їх
переслідує ідея, за якою слідують,
і вони роблять усе,
щоб перетворити ідею на щось дійсно
цінне,
гарні слова чи знаєте ви, хто сказав, що
Олександр Грем Белл чи чули
прізвище,
яким він був ученим
винахідник і вчитель,
і його найвідоміший винахід - це,
безумовно, телефон,
що ще ми знаємо про цього відомого
винахідника,
тому я скажу вам три твердження,
і ваше завдання - вирішити, які з них
правдиві, а які хибні
твердження номер один
мати і дружина обидві були глухі
обидва слухняні глухі
погано чули хто тут,
що ви думаєте, правда чи неправда
це правда, безсумнівно,
обидві його кохані жінки були глухіми
не чув, і тому
всі його слова були про те, щоб допомогти
людям з обмеженими можливостями отримати
заяву номер два
він став професором фізіології вокалу
в Бостонському університеті у віці
26 років
професором у віці 26 років
чи можливо так,
для belle це було  можливо,
він дійсно став професором
університету
в такому ранньому віці на
початку кар'єри,
і заява номер три
в 1876 році Беллу була надана його патент на телефон,
але потім цей патент був
відкликаний, вилучений у нього
медібрально, тому ми знаємо
Олександра Грема Белла як  відомий
винахідник телефону так, він отримав свій патент,
і чи може це бути правдою,
але насправді
цей патент був вилучений у
Белла,
але Олександру Грему Беллу
вдалося виграти свій патент у Верховному суді,
так що тепер ви знаєте принаймні три
факти
про цього винахідника  хотів би дізнатися
більше
ми подивимося відео
про його біографію ваше завдання
уважно слухати і вловлювати географічні
назви
зверніть увагу на місце
Там, де працював Олександр Грем Белл, він
підготував його винаходи і все,
що пов’язано з його
життям,
він експериментував з телеграфом, який
міг надсилати більше одного повідомлення одночасно
, використовуючи різні
звукові частоти, і,
працюючи над цим,
він почав вірити, що він  міг
винайти спосіб передачі людського голосу
по проводах
[Музика]
Белл не мав особливого успіху зі своїм
винаходом до
1874 року, коли він зустрів Томаса
Вотсона, конструктора-електрика та механіка, який
допоміг йому в роботі
10 березня 1876 року
Олександр Грем Белл отримав свою  телефон
на роботу
він сказав містер Уотсон, приходьте сюди, я хочу
вас побачити
Томас Вотсон, який був в іншій кімнаті,
почув голос Белль і прийшов побачити,
що телефон працює
менше ніж через шість місяців тому
проводилися телефонні демонстрації, а
цікаві люди стояли поруч,
дивуючись чути  Голоси людей за кілька
миль від винаходу Белла
незабаром лунають тисячі й тисячі людей
володіють телефонами
після успіху
Олександр Грем Белл одружився
і створив сім'ю,
хоча він найбільш відомий
винаходом телефону,
він винайшов багато інших речей протягом
свого життя,
включаючи металошукач, бездротовий
телефон, який передавав сигнал
світлом,
пристрій для виявлення айсбергів.  винахід
для виявлення
проблем зі слухом і багато іншого
в 1915 році Белл зробив перший
трансконтинентальний телефонний дзвінок
, коли був у Нью-Йорку, він розмовляв зі
своїм старим помічником Томасом Вотсоном,
який був у Сан-Франциско, і вони чули
один одного набагато чіткіше, ніж
під час.  перший телефонний дзвінок у 1876 році.
2 серпня 1922 року у віці 75 років
Олександр Грем Белл помер у своєму будинку
в Новій Шотландії, Канада,
коли він помер, усі телефони в Північній
Америці були вимкнені
й мовчали по-своєму,
тож вам вдалося зловити географічні
назви з відео
скільки з них ви спіймали давайте
перевіримо
чи чули ви ці
місця подивіться в правій
колонці події з дзвінка  життя йдіть
у хронологічному порядку,
давайте перевіримо, наскільки добре ви виконали завдання,
тому Олександр Грем Белл
народився в
[Музика]
Единбурзі, правильно ви, він поїхав жити
зі своїм дідом
до Лондона, він переїхав сюди
в 1871 році. Куди він переїхав
Бостон, правильно ти, Белл зробив свій перший
трансконтинентальний телефонний дзвінок
з Нью-Йорка і
Олександр Грем Белл помер у
Намаскотії Канада
гарна робота давайте
цього разу послухаємо більше
ми зосередимося на етапах
винаходу телефону ми прослухаємо
частину того самого відеозапису та  на цей
раз,
будь ласка, зосередьтесь на цих датах
1876 березень
і через півроку
готовий до роботи, він експериментував з
телеграфом, який міг надсилати більше одного
повідомлення одночасно, використовуючи різні звукові
частоти,
і, працюючи над цим, він
почав вірити, що він може винайти
Спосіб передачі людського голосу
по проводах
[Музика]
Белл не мав особливого успіху з його
винаходом до
1874 року, коли він зустрів Томаса
Вотсона, дизайнера-електрика і  механік, який
допомагав йому в роботі
10 березня 1876 року
Олександр Грем Белл запрацював телефон,
він сказав, містер Уотсон, приходьте сюди, я хочу
вас побачити,
Томас Вотсон, який був в іншій кімнаті,
почув голос Белль і прийшов побачити,
що телефон працював
менше ніж  через шість місяців
проводилися телефонні демонстрації, а
допитливі люди стояли поруч,
дивуючись, чуючи голоси людей за кілька
миль, які
незабаром виникли від винаходу Белла,
тож те, що сталося в ті роки
Олександр Грем Белл зустрів
свого партнера Уотсона
1876 року в березні у
них вперше з'явився телефон  все-таки подзвоніть
не на велику відстань,
і майже через півроку
вони продемонстрували його
винахід для громадськості.
Інше питання,
які значні винаходи
Белла, крім телефону,
дуже важливо, що
ви чули про них, а зараз
ми послухаємо іншу частину
запис
будьте готові зловити його
винаходи пам'ятаєте винаходи
тисячі і тисячі людей володіють
телефоном  Нес
після успіху свого винаходу
Олександр Грем Белл одружився
і створив сім'ю,
хоча він найбільш відомий
винаходом телефону,
він винайшов багато інших речей протягом
свого життя,
включаючи металошукач, бездротовий
телефон, який передавав сигнал за допомогою
світла пристрій  виявляти айсберги винахід
виявляти проблеми з чиїмось
слухом
і більше скільки інших винаходів
ми ловимо, порахуйте їх
добре давайте
перевіримо металошукач бездротовий телефон,
який передавав сигнал без
світлового
дроту менше найкраще відвести
бездротовий повторити слово
бездротовий а  пристрій
для виявлення айсбергів, щоб виявити,
щоб перевірити, виявити
це і винахід для виявлення
проблем з чиїмось слухом,
безумовно, ви пам'ятаєте про
дружину
і матір Белль, вони обидві були
глухі, так, глухі, тому що у них були
проблеми зі слухом.
скористайтеся зчитувачем qr-коду
у своєму телефоні,
і на цьому сайті
ви можете знайти  Подальше
прослуховування того самого
запису добре, і ми
продовжуємо урок,
тому, коли ми сьогодні говоримо про
телефони, давайте вивчимо деякі телефонні
дієслова, перш за все,
коли ми хочемо подзвонити комусь,
ми говоримо, що ми робимо
або робимо телефонні дзвінки.
робити телефонні дзвінки
повторювати за мною робити телефонні дзвінки
робити телефонні дзвінки я хочу зробити телефонний
дзвінок
отримати ще кілька мереж
давайте подивимося на них дзвонити
дзвонити, щоб зателефонувати утримати на
утриманні на очікуванні ми говоримо
просто зачекайте хвилину або через  іншими словами
,
утримуйте, будь ласка, утримуйте,
щоб підняти
трубку, щоб відповісти на телефонний дзвінок, і
іноді зв'язок настільки поганий, що
ми обриваємось, обриваємо,
немає зв'язку, ми не чуємо один одного
дуже легко  фразове дієслово will
you call me back
передзвонити
і покласти трубку, щоб завершити телефонну
розмову
покласти трубку давайте вивчити
ще кілька слів на тему
телефон подивіться на них
ємнісний сенсорний екран
до речі, ці слова ще про
той старий телефон  один, винайдений Олександром
Грехемом Беллом
або його правнуком,
наш нинішній смартфон, безумовно,
сказав усі ці слова, які ми використовуємо, говорячи
про
наші нинішні смартфони, і перший,
ще
один ємнісний сенсорний ємнісний екран,
який дозволяє нам
робити будь-що на
ньому друге слово сканування відбитків пальців
сканування
відбитків пальців сканування відбитків пальців повторюйте за
мною
сканування відбитків пальців гарна
робота третя фраза розпізнавання
обличчя розпізнавання обличчя,
коли ваш телефон може розпізнати ваше
обличчя,
тому фраза є розпізнавання обличчя
повторити розпізнавання моди
розпізнавання обличчя
отримати наступний прогнозний
текст
прогнозний текст прогнозний текст повторити
прогнозний текст що  чи означає це,
коли ви починаєте вводити слово
, не потрібно його заповнювати, ваш
телефон
може зробити це замість вас так,
він може передбачити дані, яке слово
ви вводите, і введіть його замість цього,
оскільки воно має функцію передбачуваного
введення тексту, а останнє
подвійний або потрійний об'єктив
ми говоримо  ng про камери так
подвійний або навіть потрійний
об'єктив linzer lens
так подвійний або потрійний об'єктив
камера добре
давайте прочитаємо ці слова в довільному порядку,
готові давайте почнемо як вимовляти цю
фразу
прочитати її сканування відбитків пальців
добре що це за прогнозний
текст добре тоді як сказати перше
ємнісний сенсорний екран
ємнісний ємнісний повторити ще раз
ємнісний nice остання
камера з подвійним або потрійним об'єктивом,
де об'єктив означає об'єктив,
об'єктив, камера, яка є камерою,
безумовно, для цього,
а та, що залишилася, це
розпізнавання обличчя розпізнавання обличчя розпізнавання обличчя,
вона може
розпізнавати так, розпізнавання обличчя
вашого телефону  pieznaia
твоє обличчя приємно
давайте подумаємо разом поглянемо на
питання,
чому винахід телефону часто
називають
революційним,
які можуть бути причинами
і друге питання, який вплив
це справило
на технічний прогрес вплив
перевернути вплив повторити слово
вплив отримати
подумайте про це  наскільки важливим був
цей винахід, коли ви
готові говорити про себе
Ви можете знайти
цю програму на своєму смартфоні, чи знаєте ви,
як вона може вам допомогти,
я скажу вам
висловити свої ідеї щодо питань і
записати себе,
що робити, а потім прослухайте свою промову
та проаналізуйте, чи це звучить логічно,
чи не так?  зробіть будь-які помилки, подумайте, як
покращити
та записати ще раз.
Запис слухайте та покращуйте
це свого роду цикл, і це ваш шлях
до найкращого виступу,
добре обійміться наживо.
інваліди
тепер наш час подумати, як ми можемо
допомогти
людям подумати про проблему, з якою стикаються
окремі
чи групи людей у нинішньому українському су
пільстві, що
уде винаходом, який міг би до
омогти їм зр
бити ескіз, подібний до того, який ви ба
или добре, і бу
и готовим  щоб пояснити, яку проблему
ваш винахід може допомогти вирішити,
що робити далі, ви можете отримати
відгук про свою письмову роботу,
подивіться, якщо ви напишете
свої ідеї та маєте хештег
домашнє завдання, спочатку дозвольте  ers nine
done обіцяють, що щодня
я буду перевіряти щонайменше 10 робіт
і надсилатиму вам відгук, чи хочете ви,
щоб це було
добре, але справа не тільки в мові,
зміст ваших винаходів
дійсно
важливий, тому
найцікавіші ідеї будуть
винагороджений подивіться на це я думаю, що ця книга буде
вам
дуже корисною, тому я обіцяю, що
ця книга винагородить кілька ідей,
чи звучить це багатообіцяюче, безсумнівно,
готові до вашого домашнього завдання
добре і чашка стремена нашого сьогоднішнього
уроку
подивіться на це чи знаєте ви, що Олександр
Грем Белл
відмовився мати телефон у своєму кабінеті,
боячись, що це відверне
його від наукової роботи,
і ви дякую,
слухайте, дзвінок дзвонить,
тому наш урок закінчено, дякую за
участь
і до скорої зустрічі  привіт
[музика]
ти